>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
TO MONITOR CARTER PAGE
WITHOUT HIS KNOWING IT
ASKING WHEN IT IT ACCEPTABLE
TO SPY ON U.S. CITIZENS?
HAS THE NORM BECOME IT'S
ALWAYS ACCEPTABLE FOR THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT TO SPY ON
INTERCEPT HE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME COVERING THE AMERICAN
SURVEILLANCE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I SHOULDN'T
INTEREST OF HONESTY NOTE THE
IRONY CONGRESS JUST
REAUTHORIZED THE LAW THAT
MADE THIS POSSIBLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND DID SO WITH
VERY LITTLE PUBLIC DEBATE ON
THE SUBJECT THAT RAISES A
MORE BASIC QUESTION WHY IS
THIS QUESTION WHEN AND HOW
IS THAT SO RARELY DEBATED IN
PUBLIC?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
WHY EDWARD SNOWDEN RISKED
GOING TO PRISON BECAUSE HE
STATE WAS BEING CONSTRUCTED
IN SECRET DIRECTED NOT JUST
AT FOREIGN ADVERSARIES BUT
INWARD, DOMESTICALLY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WITHOUT
ANYBODY KNOWING ABOUT IT.
NEVER DISCUSSED WHAT THE
PARAMETERS ARE.
DEMOCRATS WARNING TRUMP IS
LAWLESS TYRANT ENDANGERING
DEMOCRACY.
ENDANGERING DEMOCRACY BY
ABUSING ITS POWER.
THE DEMOCRATS, THE
LEADERSHIP BY THE WAY NOT
THE MAJORITY GOT TOGETHER
AUTHORED THE MEMO TODAY AND
NOT JUST MORE THAN TWO WEEKS
AGO VOTED TO INCREASE SPYING
POWER AND BLOCK ALL
SAFEGUARDS ON HOW IT'S USED.
IT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE NOW
TO WATCH IT DEBATE UNFOLD.
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY ALMOST
NAUSEATING AND AS I SAID
TOTALLY IRONIC.
SO YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT HOW
THIS WORKS.
WHAT IS LEGAL AND WHAT IS
JUDGE OR SERIES OF JUDGES IN
ORDER TO LEGALLY SPY ON A
U.S. CITIZEN?
>> SO IN ORDER TO TARGET A
U.S. CITIZEN THE WAY THEY
ARE GOING TO LISTEN TO ALL
OF HIS PHONE CALLS, READ HIS
OR A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION
SO THEY CONVINCED A FISA
COURT JUDGE THAT THERE IS
PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE
THAT CARTER PAGE IS AN AGENT
OF THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: HOW OFTEN ARE
THOSE REQUESTS TURNED DOWN.
DO WE KNOW?
>> ALMOST NEVER SOMETHING
LIKE 99.8% APPROVAL RATING.
THE FISA COURT IS A JOKE IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT IT
PROVIDES REAL SAFEGUARDS OR
OVERSIGHT FOR HOW THE NSA
AND THE FBI CAN SPY ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THEY BASICALLY RUBBER STAMP
WHATEVER IT IS THAT IS PUT
IN FRONT OF THEM.
DEMOCRATS USED TO SAY THAT A
LOT.
BUT WHEN GEORGE BUSH AND
DICK CHENEY GOT CAUGHT
SPYING ON AMERICANS WITHOUT
GOING TO THE FISA COURT THE
ARGUMENT IN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION IT IS SO
BURDENSOME.
DEMOCRATS SAY IT'S SO EASY
PROCESS THEY ALMOST NEVER
SAY NO.